PAH the reason why put this very
question in okay it's so that you can
see a couple of things firstly one more
okay now you can choose whichever axis
access to what if you did it around this
way for instance okay we're doing by
slices first so you take a slice out
like that perpendicular to your axis of
rotation and then if I take that part
out it'll look something like this okay
so you work that out so you add up a
bunch of these well since it has no
inner radius on your atomizer bunch of
circles no problem
okay here you do a slice or an area
across that way right I'm still rotating
the same direction okay so when this
comes out it's gonna look like this
right and there's my cylindrical shell
okay and of course you can unfold that
you get a rectangle no problems okay
now the really cool thing is you can add
up a bunch of circles you can add up a
bunch of cylinders which turn into
rectangles you can add up anything so
long as you they're paper-thin whether
its Delta X or Delta Y right and so long
as all of them look the same right like
if I took this slice over here it would
still look the same just smaller right
and if I took this slice over here it'll
be the same just you know you see what's
going on okay
now therefore here's the real clincher
right and it makes sense in a
relationship which I hope you've enjoyed
and puzzling over for a long time you
can take circles you can take shells but
you could also treat this kind of like
we treat it like an onion right now an
onion right it's got layers that don't
go across like this or up and down like
this each layer is itself well it's
longer it's not a cylindrical shell
it's a spherical shell right a spherical
shell so I could say look I want to take
the limit as Delta now hold on a second
hold on a second here you've got Delta X
whose horizontal you've got Delta Y what
is the width of one of these cylindrical
shells in terms of it's not X it's not
like it's in terms of radius right if I
if I draw these hole out right there's a
delta ah okay coming from the center
coming out to the edge right so if I
think about this okay now I'm gonna I'm
gonna add up a whole bunch right it's
going to be well x equals from the
center all that out to the addresses
okay now you know what the area of an
annular disc is you know what the area
of a cylindrical shell is what is the
area of a spherical shell and the answer
is it's on its surface area isn't it
its surface area right and of course
that's the at the area and then you
multiplied by the thickness okay
turn this guy into an integral on that
for pi you just check out the front
right from north ah what what ah squared
D ah oh oh right okay they go they're
constant now immediately I said do it my
slices through advise cylindrical shells
I did not say do it by spherical shells
right probably cuz that's not really in
the course but but have you wondered
about this and when you first learn
differentiation did anyone get
suspicious that the derivative right of
the volume equation from equals the
surface area equation what's with that
did anyone did anyone have noticed that
the derivative of the area of a circle
is the circumference why is that because
because if you want to work out the area
of a circle you just take a bunch of
circumference thank you card okay
you add them all up and you end up with
your area okay